look at look at how he look let's pull
up a young pic of joe rogan when he was
in his heyday i mean the kid
was an absolute bona fide [ __ ] piece
wow
yeah now he looks like he's got a
fighter's face like he looks like he's
been a couple of times
he's got some scar tissue but when he
was young he had hair
i mean the kid had nice hair yeah he had
a nice hair and now he's
got a shaved head but he's got this he
looks good in the shaved head and
obviously he's got the biggest podcast
in the world
um and uh and yeah no but the kid listen
joe rogan
is i mean listen as successful as he is
and and as
great as everything he's i mean we all
got demons i mean the kid sleeps in a
[ __ ] sleep deprivation tank every
night i mean the kids
[ __ ] sleeps upside down like a bat
because he hunts his own food
he hunts on food i mean yeah he he
sleeps in a in a
in some cryonic chamber i mean yeah he
does dmt every day i mean we're all
running from something yeah
the beans and cause here's an
interesting thing about rogan which i
think a lot of people know but then
don't realize what happened in 2005
rogan accused carlos mancia of jokes
chilling which he was
and then in 2007 he confronted mencia on
stage at the comedy store and now
now you associate joe rogan with the
comedy store and it's like he made it he
built it and he did
but in 2007 the comedy store employees
sided with carlos mencia and rogan got
dropped by his
talent agent in gersch his man i think
his manager stayed with him but he got
banned from the comedy store and from
2007 to 2013
wasn't allowed in the comedy store for
six freaking years and in that time
frame
he made joe rogan uh the joe rogan
experience jre
and the first time he came back in 2013
was to support our shapiro's first
special
so it's just like you got to understand
one thing the
the joe rogan is the
is like you know we know this but maybe
the the public doesn't know
is like the johnny carson of our time
like how you heard of
jerry seinfeld and ray romano and all
these
drew carey because they broke on the
johnny carson show that's what joe rogan
was for r shafir and tom segura and
burke chrysler and theo vaughn they
broke
on the joe rogan show so they went on
we're amazing funny talented and then
boom you hear about them yeah so that's
how
tim dillon dill and andrew schultz i
mean all these guys work hard and have
amazing things
but funny the thing that got them to
rogan was there
things they were doing before talented
and work ethic and all that but then the
major platform
to give them the success they have much
like carson is is
is uh is joe rogan so we just
like many things in our career we miss
the boat again that's what it is
that's and that's why it's extremely
important for us as comedians
to have someone like joe rogan because
like giannis mentioned the gatekeepers
there used to be people who were
gatekeepers to get you into this
festival get you on this tv network and
do this and they could
they held your career in their hands but
they weren't comedians
joe rogan now being a gatekeeper who is
a comedian
and it's kind of like real recognize is
real if you're talented and you're good
and he respects you
he gives you an opportunity by just
saying come on my show and then
you know you listen to the episodes
especially with comedians he lets the
comedians talk and showcase their skills
he doesn't try to get the last word in
or
he knows what it is he's become the
platform in his own way so he's very you
know
we're all appreciative even if you know
we never you know never been on a show
we hope to someday
but even though we haven't it's like
it's just amazing just to know that
there's
if if a network a tv network or somebody
wants to see
nobody can cancel you or take your
career away as long as you got joe rogan
and his show behind you
yeah i mean his career has been
interesting because
he didn't at the beginning supposedly he
didn't even wanna he didn't see himself
becoming a comedian
he saw he thought he was gonna become
like a kickboxing instructor
he stopped fighting um around age 21 or
whatever
dropped out of college um he saw
his big inspiration was he saw richard
pryor special and he was blown away by
how funny he was
and that's what made him want to become
a comedian he started comedy in 1988.
yeah he's been around for a long time i
mean yeah and the kid moves tickets but
i mean when you look at him now he's
still they're both handsome but they're
two
different type of handsome yeah one is
like a little more pretty boyish and
this is the kid
who just looks like he will [ __ ] he
will go
outside and kill the bear that's in your
lawn
either way he's gonna get softly kissed
on his [ __ ] lips yeah he'll get
softly kissed on his butt cheeks if we
ever get on that show because if he gets
too [ __ ] aggro with us we will
de-escalate him yeah i'll de-escalate
lieutenant lollipop sergeant will show
up and i will jerk off joe rogan live on
the show
and his producer jamie tool get jerked
off we really hope you enjoyed that
episode whatever it was about this is
just a stock thing that we're taping on
to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild